8 actors we lost far too soon
Hollywood loves the young and beautiful, and
it's easy to think of our favorite stars as
being immortal up on the big screen. Sadly,
that isn't the case, and a number of actors
have given us sobering reminders of just how
fragile life can be. Here are eight examples
of talented performers we lost far too soon.
Paul Walker
An action movie veteran who served as a cornerstone
of The Fast and The Furious franchise, Paul
Walker had broader ambitions beyond starring
in your average action flick. He branched
out with projects like the Hurricane Katrina-inspired
Hours, and the ensemble comedy Pawn Shop Chronicles.
There's really no telling what he might have
been able to accomplish if he'd survived the
tragic car crash that took his life at the
age of 40 in November 2013.
Heath Ledger
He may have gotten his start on Australian
television, but the first glimpse of Heath
Ledger's gifts for worldwide audiences came
courtesy of the 1999 teen comedy 10 Things
I Hate About You. Ledger's work as the brooding
teen Patrick Verona, while certainly one of
the movie's highlights, didn't really hint
at the depth of his talent, which was only
exposed after he shrugged off his shot at
Hollywood hunkdom in favor of taking on more
challenging parts in pictures like Monster's
Ball and Brokeback Mountain. For many, Ledger's
defining role came as the Joker in The Dark
Knight, which netted him a Best Supporting
Actor Oscar after his shocking death of an
accidental prescription drug overdose in early
2008. Only 28 when he died, Ledger would certainly
have gone on to even greater things.
Bruce Lee
Martial arts legend Bruce Lee made some of
the best-loved kung fu movies of all time,
and he seemed like he was only getting started.
But in 1973, at the age of 32, he died of
brain swelling, denying the world his gifts.
The Lee family's tragic history continued
in 1993, when Lee's son Brandon was accidentally
shot and killed while filming a scene during
production on The Crow. Just 28 when he died,
Brandon might have taken his father's legacy
even further; instead, his death added another
dark chapter to an already grim story.
Skye McCole Bartusiak
Though she isn't anywhere as well-known as
some of the other names on this list, Skye
McCole Bartusiak compiled an incredible repertoire
of credits during her too-brief career. A
mere 7 years old when she booked a role in
The Cider House Rules, Bartusiak went on to
star alongside such famous names as Mel Gibson
in The Patriot, Michael Douglas in Don't Say
a Word, and Hilary Swank in a stage adaptation
of The Miracle Worker. Along the way, she
also appeared in a supporting role on 24 and
was nominated three times for a Young Artist
Award. She was only 21 when she succumbed
to an accidental drug overdose in 2014.
River Phoenix
Getting his acting start at the tender age
of 10, River Phoenix quickly found fame through
memorable appearances in '80s movies like
Stand by Me and Explorers. Tempted with teen
idol status, Phoenix mostly avoided paycheck
roles, focusing instead on roles in films
like The Mosquito Coast, Little Nikita, and
Running on Empty. But while he led a serious
actor's life on the big screen, his personal
affairs were sadly far more stereotypical
for Young Hollywood. His dangerous habits
caught up with him in the fall of 1993, when
the 23-year-old Phoenix collapsed outside
a Los Angeles club after overdosing on multiple
drugs.
John Belushi
Part of what audiences loved about comic actor
John Belushi during his breakout years on
Saturday Night Live was his wild, untameable
image. While that manic, outsized energy was
great for SNL and movies like Animal House,
it was only part of a lifestyle that was far
too intense to last. As Belushi's stardom
continued to rise with 1980's Blues Brothers
and a host of planned projects that would
have highlighted his dramatic range, his chemical
indulgences continued to worsen. Despite the
best efforts of friends and loved ones concerned
for his well-being, Belushi succumbed to a
drug overdose in March of 1982, at the age
of 33.
Chris Farley
His infectious energy and ample girth provoked
plenty of John Belushi comparisons after Chris
Farley joined the cast of Saturday Night Live
in the spring of 1990. Sadly, the two stars
also shared similarities off-screen, and like
Belushi, Farley's SNL tenure was shadowed
by concerns for his long-term health. In spite
of his personal demons, Farley branched out
into a promising film career that included
the 1995 cult classic Tommy Boy—but after
he was fired from SNL the same year. He never
really came close to achieving his potential.
Like Belushi, Farley was only 33 at his time
of death, the sad result of a drug overdose
in December 1997.
Philip Seymour Hoffman
Arguably one of the greatest actors of his
generation, Philip Seymour Hoffman carved
out a solid niche for himself as one of Hollywood's
"that guy" supporting players. Eventually,
Hoffman got a leg up from director Paul Thomas
Anderson, who cast him in a series of productions
starting with 1996's Hard Eight. As his profile
rose, Hoffman bounced between arthouse dramas,
mainstream comedies, and even blockbuster
action pictures like Mission: Impossible III
and the Hunger Games franchise. Sadly, he
also struggled with substance abuse. After
more than 20 years of sobriety, he relapsed
in 2013, overdosing on a mixture of drugs
early the following year, at the age of 46.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one you
just saw. And leave us a comment to let us
know what other actors you loved that were
lost far too soon...